hello legends good to see you all hello
so a hundred percent fresh on rotten
tomatoes critics and audiences love the
first season marty is that is that
something that makes you feel like
excited about them seeing the second
season or is there sort of the
expectation
that you got to live up to something now
well it's all those things i mean i i
think that the first
you've seen the first half six episodes
so you know they're they're pretty
strong so if they weren't you'd feel
more apprehension
but there's always this concern of a
letdown second season but i don't think
we do
is there some sort of special do you get
a plaque to get a trophy if you get a
100 do they send you anything at all
i haven't gotten anything
i got a plan but i made it myself yeah
yeah uh i got nothing from it except uh
you know there's is a certain feel-good
factor because you know i don't know
about selena but i know marty and i've
had
complicated results of things we've done
where people love them and hate them and
expecting great reviews and they're
horrible and this so to have a hundred
percent of anything is something that
just doesn't really happen
and i assume there'll be a backlash and
there'll be a little bit of a backlash
this season
i bet not for all three of us
love yourself too much
well that i think that's also a sign
that people are invested right
steve i want to ask you about um working
with shirley maclaine uh
what's it like on the day when you're
getting ready to do a scene with her do
you know what choices she's going to
make or does she like to keep you on
your toes no she was kept me on my toes
quite a bit
and
she was completely unpredictable
and i actually loved it because you know
it's like when you're playing tennis
with someone you know if they hit it to
the left you go to the left they hit it
to the right you go to the right and
you know you just have to respond as a
true actor to really listen to what
she's saying
get the inflection and respond to the
inflection and not just what you have
pre-planned so i loved it i loved it and
also i was you know it reminded me when
i first did the tonight show which i
have no memory of but i i only remember
is thinking i'm doing the tonight show
while i'm out there and i i'm going to
do it i just did it it's so it's like
working with shirley maclaine i can't
believe i'm working with shirley
maclaine yeah
that's awesome what what's the energy
like when you've got you guys plus
sherlock mclean plus amy schumer must be
incredible
well the hang is fun you know
the scene we're hanging really far
that's fun
comment about amy schumer is if she's so
fast that if i would say a joke before i
had finished telling my joke she'd have
a topper for it and have finished her
sentence before i finished mine awesome
selena you have some wonderful chemistry
with cara in your scenes together what
is it like being able to create those
moments with one of your best friends
i so it's didn't feel like we were
working it was so much fun we
i mean we've known each other since we
were about 15. so
it was um
it was just a blast yeah we have we had
a great time and i felt like it was
super organic and she did a fantastic
i'm really excited
now i don't know how often you guys have
gotten this after season one but i
personally love the idea of an actual
brazos series like i love the idea of
like i want to see brazos for real for
the three of you if you could see brazos
team up with any other tv detective
who would it be
i think andy dick
because
well andy dick is the dick is the
british expression for investigator so
he has it in his name and i think
youtube would be a good team
i would say colombo
[Music]
who would you say
i have no one
well although there there is a brazos
surprise
in this season too
just so you know
very excited well
again congratulations on that 100 maybe
they're listening and they'll send you
something uh thanks so much for the time
thank you very much